foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
upstairs walking on sensor tonight Dale
Vince is the multi-millionaire
businessman bankrolling the man who
could be Britain's next prime minister
but he's also bankrolling the Eco
zealots from just stop oil bringing the
country to a standstill why I'll ask him
is the world-class Sportsman to become a
world leader now Pakistan's xpm faces
charges of corruption terrorism and
conspiracy and today he was accused of
aiding murder under house arrest Imran
joins me tonight
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening London welcome to Facebook
and our sense that Oxfam is a British
institution it's a charity that has for
many decades been famous for fighting
famine and poverty in the poorest
countries on Earth it has shop throws in
cash or many hundreds of British High
streets and Legions of volunteers
working across the planet or with the
shared aim of ending poverty which is
all very laudable nothing much to do
with pride month sparking considerable
confusion when they publish this video
how are you marking pride month this
year while lgbtqia plus people around
the world are deprived of basic safety
not protected by laws preyed on my hate
groups online and offline discriminated
against at work deprived of
opportunities when pushed to the margins
why are they doing that why were dogs
fans strained so hard to burnish woke
virtues have nothing to do with his
actual work a cynic might say has a lot
to do with his battered reputation in
recent years its workers were found to
have abused young girls in Haiti and
Chad and attempted to cover it up
unsurprisingly this video has faced a
stunning backlash online not just
because it's such an obvious toe curling
virtue signaling load of nonsense but
because it also contains a pretty
outrageous image of three demonic
figures bullying gay and trans people
and one of them wearing a bad saying
Turf is very obviously supposed to be JK
Rowling Turf stands for Trans
exclusionary radical feminist it's what
all the trans Lobby call anybody who
dares to stand up to their agenda and
it's just a hateful slur used by a
hateful mob to vilify usually women
standing up for women now JK Rowling has
faced years of aggression bile threats
and abuse the defending women's rights
like a lot of women especially women who
suffer domestic abuse like she has
writing is very legitimate concerns
about harder women's rights being
sacrificed under the false flag of
inclusion concerns about the word woman
being erased concerned about male
rapists going to female prisons
concerned about safe places for women
being opened up to anybody who just says
they're a woman
well fair enough you might think but for
a charity like oxfap to slur people like
JK Rowling as demons for doing that is
frankly appalling and they are precisely
the kind of people who work tirelessly
in Oxfam shops among most of its
products Oxfam has now apologized and
implaus will be denied any link to JK
Rowley even though it obviously was
supposed to be her but it has form this
is the same Oxfam which recently
published a hysterical inclusive
language guide ordering everyone to use
words like people who menstruate instead
of woman it's the same Oxfam has come
from exploiting young girls to
demonizing older women who want to
protect women's rights enough of this
if your aim is to erase poverty Oxfam
we're with you all the way if it's the
police language stifle debate and smear
critics to appease Wicked mobs on
Twitter
well we'll take our donation somewhere
else
well we'll debate to that later but
first prime minister Rishi sunak has
arrived in Washington for a two-day
visit that will involve a meeting with
President Biden at the White House is
already bottled under throwing the first
pitch in a baseball game usually an
honor granted to VIP so why would he do
that when you say good at Cricket come
on Rishi
but can he repair the special
relationship or is it just a British
fantasy well joining me now from
Washington just talk to me political
education can or he's interviewed the
Prime Minister today so Kate um a big
big trip this isn't it for Rishi sunak
over in Washington meeting the president
they're rolling out the red car but he's
already bottled the baseball which I
think is ridiculous he should have done
it taken his chances he can throw a
cricket ball we can certainly throw a
baseball
um but what's what's the mood about
Rishi sunac over there
yeah it's a really interesting one peers
these trips are always watched really
carefully for people to see how well the
two men the president the Prime Minister
get on is the back slapping that they
look like they're friends or is it a bit
of an icy relationship and this is no
different in fact it's probably even
more important because outside of the
European Union Rishi sunak is using this
opportunity to make the case that the UK
should be at the Forefront of what he
believes will be one of the most
difficult areas of policy making in the
next 10 years artificial intelligence
he's here to sell the idea that he's the
man for the job he wants to work with
President Biden as a leader in this
field of course we know how important AI
is in America but I think the big
question for issues do not care is
whether that message is really going to
penetrate we know that America is always
America first it's why trade deal talk
is firmly off the table we also know
that the Americans have their own agenda
when it comes to the economy and
probably AI too and that the UK isn't
necessarily the first option when it
comes to working out a code of conduct
which they are already talking to the
European Union about so that question of
the special relationship how special is
it can it be rebooted if you like which
is what the Prime Minister hopes is very
much open and we'll all be watching that
meeting between the two men very
carefully tomorrow I think well I'll be
watching to see if President Biden even
knows how to pronounce Richie's soon
next name remember this when sunak won
the race to be Pierre just today we've
got news for Russia
is now the prime minister
[Applause]
Ed Sanuk I mean that was pretty
breathtaking to get both parts of his
name wrong
um you actually did ask the Prime
Minister today about this which I
thought was very brave and quite correct
let's take a look
I mean do you think President Biden gets
it though I mean he's got your name
wrong twice I think it is now I mean it
doesn't leave people with a huge amount
of confidence in his ability to keep up
with I mean the pace of change of UK
prime ministers let alone artificial
intelligence well actually we discussed
artificial intelligence when we were in
Japan together the president and I and I
know he is also aware of the challenges
and opportunities that it poses in fact
the US and the UK are the I think the
only two countries that have hosted all
the major artificial intelligence
companies together in one Forum I did
that in Downing Street a few weeks ago
the president of the White House did
that a little while ago as well so I
think both of us are thinking about
these things in the same way
well said Rasheed um so okay I mean look
he's very diplomatic there but there's
no doubt Biden's age and his performance
at the moment he keeps either falling
over stumbling you know saying the wrong
thing it is a concern isn't it when the
leader of the Free World looks to be
basically cognitively incompetent
yeah and I think actually that feeds
into why Rishi sunak believes now is the
prime time for him to take the
opportunity and to offer to lead on AI
artificial intelligence in fact I went
on to ask him again during that exchange
do you think that Biden gets it because
you know this is in some Essences you
know it's a Young Person's game it's a
brand new technology a lot of us I
included I don't understand it fully we
should definitely know more about it so
I pushed the Prime Minister again and
said you know is it really something
that a young leader like yourself ought
to be leading on and he was very careful
in the approach that question no prime
minister is going to arrive in America
and criticize an American president but
I think there are some concerns behind
the scenes not just on the British side
but others too about the American
president about the potential for him to
go on to continue to be the American
president and whether you know he has
his eye on this whether it's policy
making in other areas is right I mean we
know that we should see next uh attitude
if you like to some of his economic
overseas is not let's say aligned so I
think it's certainly a concern and it'll
be really fascinating to watch tomorrow
that the relationship and the attitude
between those two men because Biden
himself has taken that on and said yeah
I make mistakes not one every press
conference but I do make them but I
think it's fair to say he probably makes
more than most other leaders that we can
all uh we can all think about yeah well
it will be gripping tomorrow and we will
have you back on Piers Morgan unscented
twice in the same week I feel so spoiled
came again thank you
uh but have fun over there and I'm
jealous I wish I was there I love
Washington uh good to see you Kate we'll
talk tomorrow you can watch the whole of
Kate in a full interview we wish you
soon like tonight on first edition at 10
pm
well just in some breaking news Lionel
Messi uh who just won the World Cup of
course with Argentina has signed for the
American MLS football team into Miami
from Paris Saint-Germain so this
confirms rumors swirling all day and
he's apparently giving a press
conference about this imminently we'll
try and have a bit of that later than me
in the show but uh apparently got
offered over a billion dollars to go and
play in Saudi Arabia where he would have
been of course up against his old rival
Cristiano Ronaldo but it looks like he's
now taken the American dollar and will
be playing in Miami so more from that
later
well two years ago the green power
millionaire Dale Vince gave 10 000
pounds to an upstart protest group
called just top oil no one had heard of
them then they certainly have now though
they've brought Rose to a standstill
they bound their necks to goal posts at
a Premier League football match they've
wrecked the world snooker championships
by hurling orange powder across the
tables they've even sullied the sacred
Chelsea flower show Del Vince also
happens to be one of the biggest backers
of the labor party pumping 1.5 million
pounds into the party that could soon be
run in the country it's a whole point of
just stop oil is to bring climate change
to the attention of leaders why would a
man with a direct line to the potential
prime minister need to bankroll their
campaign of Torment well I spoke to him
just before the show
so I was fascinated by you uh mainly
from The Briefing notes I got given
earlier today you dropped out of school
at 15 you lived in a converted ambulance
you were too poor to afford shoes you
had to eat out of bins you haven't eaten
meat for 40 years you entered you'd
rather dive and eat me you launched your
first wind turbine off your roof in 1996
you set up a company ecotricity you now
have 200 000 customers in the UK and
you're reputed to be worth over a
hundred million pounds that's a hell of
a story
yeah that's only some of it and it's not
completely accurate but you know there's
a lot of Truth in there how long you got
oh we could probably do a longer one
time
you've hit the headlines recently
because of your support for just stop
oil and in particular your financial
support began with a ten thousand pound
donation a week ago you said you would
match any other donations in a 48-hour
period the amount range was a hundred
and seventy thousand pounds which you
doubled to 340 000 pounds that's a
significant chunk of change even for a
man of your wealth why are you so
committed to supporting just some oil
well the the cause itself I mean it's a
single purpose campaign to prevent uh
further drilling for oil and gas in the
North Sea we know that it doesn't make
sense the international scientific
consensus uh is clear we can't keep
finding new forms of fossil fuels
because we can't afford to burn them if
we're going to stay within the Paris
one-half degree Accord which we signed
up to along with the rest of the world
in 2015. uh you know the the science is
really clear from the UN from the ipcc
we're in danger of reaching three
degrees we have to transition from
fossil fuels rapidly and therefore
drilling for more and they'll take years
to come into into fruition just makes no
sense Pearson so I believe that very
strongly I think the guy's doing a great
job and I'm giving them all the support
that I can so look broadly I agree with
what you just said all right so let's
put that on the table you know when I
hear the just up all protesters when
they outline their mission statement I
find myself nodding along my problem is
with their methodology and I want to
play a clip this is a cyclist in North
London uh who identified himself as a
liberal and said this to some of the
protesters
and you all feel better about yourself
but you're hurting the cause you feel
better where you're hurting the cause
you're hurting against the Green Card
so you feel good about yourself but
you're not helping
I thought it was really interesting
because he basically supported them but
doesn't support the methods they're
using and I don't and a lot of people
don't your friend sakir starmer you've
been a big donor to the labor party and
you support him and want him to be prime
minister he doesn't support the
methodology either why are you so happy
to put hundreds of thousands of pounds
to a group who are causing a lot of
aggravation to people and don't appear
to be turning any Minds
huh well I think you know a recording of
one cyclist uh is an anecdote and a few
other people's opinions they're also
anecdotes none of that is data in if you
look uh behind the scenes just our
boilers I agree with your calls but I
agree with what he said so I don't think
he's just that guy a lot of people I
talk to have a fundamental basic
supportive view about the cause and
think we should be doing this but they
just hate what's going on now with these
protesters well I've had a few of them
in here I've got to say some of them
have behaved like complete morons which
again doesn't help the cause you're not
a you're a very very bright guy
and I think you've really you know
you've laid your own cards on the table
very firmly and dedicated yourself to
missed calls do you not think that some
of this methodology is just having the
opposite effect
well look it's definitely upsetting some
people that's what I was trying to say
but behind that there's a lot of people
that support what just stop oil are
doing because a lot of people feel
completely frustrated our governments
say the right things on the climate then
they do all the wrong things opening a
coal mine Drilling in the North Sea all
kinds of stuff maintaining the ban
onshore wind you know our fastest
cheapest cleanest form of energy it
needs no public money at all we can get
to 100 green electricity in 10 years
with no public money if the government
just enabled that but instead we have a
government pursuing old-fashioned
policies claiming that if we drill in an
old sea we can help bring energy bills
down when that's completely counter
factual we saw that from the energy
crisis last winter and of course it
flies in the teeth of the climate crisis
millions of people are frustrated by
this person I do understand and I do
accept that it also upsets people as
well
but watching you know watching these
guys jumping on snooker tables wrecking
everyone's fun at the world
championships and spraying their pains
around watching them trashing Gardens
that have been beautifully lovingly
produced and cared for for months by
people at the Chelsea flower show and so
on it's just vandalism it doesn't make
anybody think God that's great I must
support them it thinks I hate these
people so again I come back to you know
you are a smart guy you must know that
this is not the right way to get what
they want or what you want
well look I think with the conservative
government nothing is the right way to
get what we want in terms of the climate
crisis that we face this government are
tone deaf completely in in hockton
fossil fuel interest and just the old
way of doing things it's out of sheer
frustration that these people uh behave
in this way and campaign in this way and
I understand that I do understand also
that it aggravates people but look
Pierce in the background there's a
greater harm being done the climate
crisis itself killed 40 000 people in
Europe last last summer when we had
those record high temperatures this is
not a one-off event it's happening all
around the world because of freak
weather there's this big thing coming
called the climate crisis driven by
fossil fuels and we absolutely can't
afford to be drilling for any more
so we had a lot of agreement other than
methodology about a lot of what he was
talking about but next delve into now
where we locked horns about his liking
for food that involves the Monstrous B
murdering vegan hypocrisy it's the
little guys I care about we'll talk
about them next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
welcome back to Facebook Del Vince is a
vegan of 40 years who claimed he'd
rather dive and eat meat which is
interesting because I'd rather die than
be a vegan even runs the world's first
vegan football club it's like I said in
the second part of our interview I
exposed well a little bit of the
hypocrisy which goes around so many of
these vegans it gets quite Lively this
you're a vegan have been for a very long
time and a survey came out by the United
Nations food and agriculture
organization last week I think it was
that founded a vegan diet cannot provide
some vital nutrients to 500 scientific
papers and they concluded that basically
you can't get enough nutrients from
plant-based food sources which would fly
in the face of what you believe about a
vegan diet so could it be and I put this
to you respectfully Dale that you're
just maybe wrong again
look I had a quick read of that study it
was a few weeks ago it seemed to me to
be aimed at parts of the world where
intensive agriculture is not possible
and they talked about marginal diets and
how to prevent stunting of children and
they were arguing that actually grazing
animals in those countries and eating
animals was uh was a better alternative
than vegan foods I think it was a very
specific case they were looking at
because the science is very clear take
vitamin B12 for example because animals
don't make that and 97 of all of the
vitamin B12 that we make man-made
vitamin B12 in the world is fed to
animals because they live in sheds and
they aren't exposed to the grass where
they would normally get it from it's the
complete myth that we need animals for
B12 and vegans don't get it Bear Grylls
for example Bear Grylls has come out and
renounced his vegan Faith he's gone back
to a diet of red meat blood bone marrow
and salted butter eggs fruit and honey
he says I was vegan quite a few years
ago but I broke a vegan cook book and I
feel embarrassed about it because you
now realizes that the the future is
meaty oh what's your message to Bear is
he wrong as well
yeah look uh it's not about right or
wrong right if he feels better eating
that stuff then that's up to him uh you
know veganism plant-based living is on
the rise in our country and around the
world those people aren't wrong that's a
choice that people make if you look at
the cruelty of the animal industry it's
it's incredible it's off the charts if
you look at the fact that it's the
second biggest cause of the climate
crisis globally animal agriculture
that's off the charts and uh and then
look at the the impact on human health
we know that it's responsible for some
of the chronic diseases most of the
chronic diseases that affect us in older
life heart problems uh cancers uh you
know diabetes all that kind of stuff
these are scientific facts as well so
it's not about right or wrong actually
likes us up to him right do you eat
almonds and avocados
classic I knew that was coming right
because that's what you say to vegans
yeah
sometimes but listen vegans don't live
on almonds and avocados so you've
confessed as a vegan to eating avocados
and almonds and as you know they are
made from bees in California over six
week period every year and billions of
bees get habitually murdered to feed
your avocado and almond habit along with
other vegans and they often get flown or
trucked and then around the world so on
every single level eating avocados and
almonds is bad for the planet how do you
plead look I don't have a habit to eat
either of those things you ask me if I
add them and I do occasionally eat them
but almonds come from other parts of the
world and so do avocados actually but
most of them come from California I
think you're in the business of uh of
painting pictures with extremes Pierce
and and it's not helpful
as well as a balanced diet it's more
it's more actually about principle I
don't mind people who are genuinely
principled whose Lifestyles genuinely
conform to the way that they're
preaching right and like I say I agree
with a lot of what you say but when I
hear vegans talking about this great
contribution to the planet and so on but
they all eat avocados and almonds and we
know that billions of bees get killed to
feed that and that they get flown around
the world and truck around the world and
it's all terrible for the planet I think
I'm prepared I'm I'm able to ask the
question do you not think that's
hypocritical
uh like I said I don't have a habit as
you described it I do occasionally eat
that stuff if it comes from California
or it doesn't but the bees aren't killed
are they I mean they're just used but I
think you're you're kind of dying from
the point if you eat meat and dairy
dies right everything lives and dies
everything lives in dogs
like a cow for example
cows baby cows are killed so that you
can drink cow's milk right did you know
I have no problem in did you know that
I've got no problem with animal look I
eat meat so obviously I know animals get
killed you're a vegan and you don't
agree milk I said if you drink milk if
you drink cow's milk baby cows are
killed from their mother you say bees
don't get killed did you know that well
so you have a problem you have a problem
with animals being killed
do you know do you not think it's wrong
baby you have a problem at Birth so that
you can drink it as a meat eater I
clearly don't have a problem with
animals being killed do you as a vegan
have a problem with animals being killed
I said
I'm talking about milk okay I'm talking
about I'm talking about bees are you
okay
are you okay with the death of a baby
cow so you can drink its mother's milk
is that okay I eat I eat veal I know how
that's made right I eat meat so I'm
unashamed about that you're a vegan a
principal reading the question and you
don't think bees but I would put to you
that billions of bees do actually get
slaughtered every year and that's mainly
to produce avocados and almonds
because they're bigger animals I think
the little guys matter too the little
the little bees matter they're living
things okay
so you're okay though you haven't
answered the question you're okay with
the death of a baby cow so that you can
drink its mother's milk I I'm
really fine with eating meat generally
or any consumer product that comes from
animals being killed to feed humans yeah
and by the way animals eat each other as
well so my question though for you which
remains unanswered are you okay with it
or are you wanting to take some sort of
principle stance against me for what I
eat but absolve yourself of any of any
sin yourself serious question not at all
no not at all not at all listen I'm
against the use of bees uh I don't eat
honey and stuff like that I rarely
avocados and almonds you just ask me
that favorite question of anti-vegan
presenters looking for hypocrisy right
the Big H word yeah but you still the
direct question shooting of baby calves
in the head at Birth so that you can
drink their mother's milk is that okay
yes or no you answer my question and
I'll answer you yes or no
yes or no it's not your interview that's
mine you haven't are you okay it's our
interview
answers your question you don't think
billions of bees get killed I say they
get killed demonstrably they get killed
they don't get killed they used they
used they used to pollinate the plants
over there that's what happens and and
absolutely but they don't get killed so
now I'm sorry okay they do die
everything dies everything dies bees
don't have a long lifespan so if that's
like a billion here baby cows and just
kill them to feed you that would not be
killing them it would just be natural
death would it
you still haven't answered my question
oh I'll come to it if you answer mine
I have
I have that the bees aren't killed
they're used their kidding dies they
have a short lifespan I'm not okay with
it I'm not okay with it and I don't eat
honey for example if we touched the
bottom of this issue yet will you answer
the baby cow question uh what is the
specific question you want answered
are you okay with the the murder of a
baby cow at Birth so that you can drink
its mother's milk
hey we're drinking milk yeah
donated uh 1.5 million pounds to labor
but you're also in the pandemic claimed
uh three I was 309 000 pounds of
taxpayer cash for furlough do you think
that was reasonable given how wealthy
you are and given you've got all this
money to give a labor party I'm not sure
if you understand how the furlough
scheme worked but basically it was put
in place too yeah well it was put in
place to protect jobs during the
pandemic uh to protect jobs that were no
longer there because people couldn't go
to work it was to prevent mass
redundancies and the money paid to
companies was paid directly to staff so
no company kept any money from the
furlough scheme we didn't keep any money
from the furlough scheme we simply used
it for what it was for which was to keep
people employed
you've managed to find one and a half
million pounds to give to labor since
2014. why did you need taxpayer cash to
bail out your your staff during the
pandemic why can't and you've just
diverted some of the money you gave to
labor and use that you did say since
2014 didn't you that 10-year period yeah
maybe there's the answer in there for
you these things weren't perfectly
aligned we weren't sat here saying oh
we're just going to bung this money to
labor oh look we could claim on the
furlough scheme that didn't happen like
that but nonetheless I go back to the
fundamental Point Pierce we didn't make
any money from that this was money made
available to all businesses in the
country we pay tax here in this country
we were entitled to use that our staff
were entitled for us to use that to save
their jobs okay there's nothing wrong
with what we did
anything pandemic nothing wrong
it's not connected it's not connected to
all the other things we spend money on
like just stop oil you know we give
money to all kinds of good causes and
it's unconnected it's a just a silly
attempt a despair quite frankly listen I
put the question to you you've answered
it and that's that's the point of an
interview I'm not making a judgment at
all uh Dale good to talk to you yeah
thanks see you later all the best
well nonsense the next Pakistan's former
prime minister Imran Khan so it's a
sensational new claims that he aided the
murder of a lawyer this week who was
Prosecuting him under house arrest I'll
talk to Imran next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this is talk TV
little update from Lionel Messi who's
saying he wanted to go back to Barcelona
but it was all too painful when he left
two years ago too difficult to have
control of his life Mrs kids at school
so he's gone to America we'll have an
easier time and can see his kids welcome
back to Pismo now since as we speak our
former prime minister of Pakistan Imran
Khan is on better under house arrest in
his home in Lahore describing his ordeal
on that of his supporters as custodial
torture he will return to court tomorrow
where he faces more than 150 violence
and Corruption charges and in the last
few hours he's also been formally named
by police in connection with the murder
of a lawyer seeking proceedings against
him who was gunned down this week loving
already survived an assassination
attempt in November 2022 it comes as
another dramatic twist in the life of a
man who before entering politics was
revered as a beloved cricketer and
captain of his Nation I spoke to Roman
Khan under house arrest just before we
came on air
good to see you again it seems like
every time I talk to you there's a new
crisis last time it was after the
assassination attempt now you're under
house arrest you're back in court
tomorrow
um how are you doing
well pairs I'll sell my life is pretty
exciting you never know what's going to
happen the next day
it certainly is it's certainly
unpredictable just before I came on air
today you've now been in addition to the
150 uh different violence and Corruption
charges that you're facing they've now
put your name against this murder of a
lawyer who was uh pressing for a case
against you for sedition uh who was
killed on Tuesday by full government
what is your response to that because I
don't even know the name of this guy
it's Abdul Raza again I repeat
it is the case didn't even register on
my on my radar of course I had nothing
to do with it everyone knows I had
nothing to do with it people in his
family know that I have nothing to do
with it the other challenge is Imran is
150 of them
it's a huge amount obviously if you're
convicted of this you'll go to prison
presumably for a long period of time
what do you feel about this I mean
you're back in court tomorrow you'll
just they'll decide whether you can go
back home under house arrest or
presumably whether you will be
incarcerated what is your general view
about what is happening to you
I'm I have 17 bail cases tomorrow
chances are all all the judge has to say
is that one of the bills he refuses to
give me Bill and I go to jail so I'm
mentally prepared but you know Bears
what is happening in Pakistan we are
back to the Dark Ages I mean there's no
rule of law left here
if you what what has been happening to
my party 10
000 of our workers are in jail and the
the judges give them relief and they the
police picks them up another case so it
is the law of the Jungle right now I
mean it's never happened in this country
before your critics your enemies they
say you're getting what you did to
others in the sense that the military
turned on you but to start with you had
them on your side that you when you came
into office were putting people in
prison who shouldn't have been with
trump top charges and so on you've heard
this charge against you what is your
response to that first of all it's never
happened even in military dictatorship
what is happening now but secondly do
you know 95 of the cases against the
opposition I inherited they were from
from the previous governments in fact
when they were in power
uh there were only five percent of the
cases and it was nothing like what is
going on now if you end up going to jail
for a long period of time what will
happen to you to your party to the
movement to all of it
look there's this today
why is this happening this is happening
because my party
PTI
is now the largest party in Pakistan's
history I mean the ratings of the party
has today
the all the parties on one side they
realize that they they are no match for
this party the movement is so powerful
today and that is the reason why this is
happening because they are now are
petrified the People Who removed me are
petrified that whenever an elections are
supposed to be in October
whenever their elections my party will
come back into Power hence they are
trying to completely dismantle the party
I would say that the support from world
leaders has been pretty deafening with
its silence in the main
do you wish you'd have more vocal
support from maybe the British prime
minister which is tonight the American
President Joe Biden would that be
helpful
by three and a half years as prime
minister I discovered one thing that
this morality
and the the so-called Western values
about democracy constitutionalism rule
of law uh fundamental rights against
custodial torture all that is happening
in Pakistan today yet I think the
interests of the the powers Britain the
U.S I think they are more aligned with
our military
uh for whatever reasons maybe because
they're supporting them in Ukraine
um I always wanted an independent
foreign policy because I
80 000 pakistanis died when we joined
the U.S war on terror and I was against
it so I think maybe that they feel that
their interests are more served by by
the current regime and whenever that
happens you know all these professed
values go out of the window I mean Rishi
sunak is currently in Washington with
President Biden what's your message to
both of them if they're watching this
my message is simple
firstly countries only uh sort their
problems out from Buddha but
the professed values of United States
and United Kingdom
I repeat is democracy is fundamental
rights rule of law I mean whatever they
criticize Hong Kong or China with the
uyghurs or Russia they always talk about
the lack of Human Rights and fundamental
rights and lack of democracy but here
here's one standard democracy and all
this all these values are being violated
yet not a word from them but you know I
didn't really expect much even on a
human level you know I've spoken to you
after people tried to kill you and they
came very close to killing you that was
just six months ago or so you've got a
family you've got these two young Sons
uh you tweeted recently the only thing I
missed these days is hiking in our
Northern mountains with my sons and that
was a very human thing to tweet and I as
a father of three boys not dissimilar
age to yours now that really resonated
with me how are you doing on a on a
human level
well it's a you know huge sacrifice
because what is happening right now is
we are basically fighting for rule of
law and democracy on the other hand we
now have
uh we are heading towards the worst type
of dictatorship it's a Banana Republic
right now where the judges now are no
longer independent they are threatened
media is completely muzzle my name is
not allowed to be mentioned on the media
and
you can't demolish the biggest political
party by by the the steps they've taken
these Draconian steps so therefore what
is a threat is that democracy our future
so there's the you know it is a this has
been one of the most toughest years of
my life are you able to see your sons
no I can't this is too dangerous a time
for for uh me to ask them to come over
uh and you know I'm confident that this
is uh this is not going to last very
long because the system cannot take this
much longer the Judiciary is is overall
right now it's cowed down
but the Judiciary has a past 15 years
it's asserted its independence so at the
moment it's it's you know the the terror
which is in Pakistan is a reign of
terror I mean people are frightened
people are picked up in the middle of
the night it's like in in you know in
the in the Nazi Germany you know Imran
each time I talk to you I I always
reminded that you know I spent my
formative years down at Sussex County
cricket ground watching you bowling
magnificently uh for Sussex and you were
one of my sort of Heroes then cricketing
Heroes do you ever wish you just hadn't
gone into politics I mean serious
question given the impact on your life
the dangers the threats the
assassination attempts and so on do you
ever wish you'd just you know had an
easier life
the beers look in Pakistan they're two
ways one is when you go into Politics as
a political career in my opinion
it is the worst career to ever choose I
would never suggest Politics as a career
to anyone as a career secondly is the
politics where you you are so privileged
I had more respect than any other
Pakistani and I tried I what I wanted to
do was to what I by the way what I first
saw and admired in England when I went
there as a teenager rule of law we never
had rule of law in this country because
we had
dictatorship either we had dictation
dictatorship or two families but they
never allowed people to have rule of law
where people fundamental rights were
protected and as a result
the country is not we don't we never
knew Freedom real Freedom first time I
saw was in England when I went as a
teenager and I discovered how rule of
law and fundamental rights Liberator
whole people
so Mayan movement started 27 years ago I
realized that unless we have rule of law
we have no future well I mean you will
always have a birth on Piers Morgan
uncensored I've spoken to you numerous
times in the last year it's been a quite
extraordinary period in your life
um and I'm living it vicariously sitting
here safely in London I wish you all the
very best and hope next time it's in uh
in this isn't a slightly calmer
circumstance
inshallah thank you
extraordinary what's been happening to
Imran Khan on sensitive next we get
reaction to that interview and what
about Lionel Messi who's quitting elite
football to go and play in America where
he of course had to admit it's called
soccer
what's he feel about that after the
break
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
coming up on the talk emotions run high
for Prince Harry during his final day in
the witness box Jets carrying migrants
could take off for a Wonder within weeks
and pupils are told not to call teachers
Miss because it's sexist that's all at
nine o'clock
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook ancestors I'm
joined by the former newspaper Emily
Sheffield Associated sort of Daily
Mirror Kevin McGuire welcome to both of
you start just with Imran Khan Uh Kevin
to start with which is a remarkable
thing going on with that guy yeah and
his life you know assassination attempt
now he's facing potentially many years
in prison he says it's all a fit up who
knows what's going on over there what do
you make of it yeah there's a
narcissistic side to him unquestionably
and I'm sure he's not without blemish
but nevertheless I instinctively side
with whichever politician is going to be
put in prison by the the ruling regime
and in Pakistan this is a country of 230
million people one of the largest in the
world has got nuclear weapons but the
military
has incredible and unhealthy controls in
three periods of long military rule
since Pakistan's Independence created in
1947. so I instinctively feel on Imran
Khan's side and he's at risk let's not
forget I mean the military
I literally when I was a kid used to go
and watch Sussex play cricket every week
with my brother and we used to bowl it
and run in the Nets every week right he
would let the kids bowl with him when he
was practicing for during a game and he
couldn't have been more Charming or
solicitous or no so I've always had a
soft spot for him you've got to say
regardless of where the truth lies with
all this he's got balls of steel I mean
to be shot and nearly assassinated just
six months ago and to just carry on
trying to pursue your cause over there
no and if you know as he said I mean
this is this is you saw him talk about
the new murder charge I mean the 150
allegations against him corruption
murder now you know it's it's another
move I mean that murder I mean to crush
him coming back to office as he said
himself you know he's gone from this
sort of almost like sort of Playboy the
minutes was years ago he's now 17
incredibly good looking
um cricketer who married Jemima gold yes
had two beautiful boys you know he's
gone through a serious journey and he is
facing and facing bravely the fact that
he could end up in jail and could end up
in jail for a very long time the
military are incredible by the way
unbelievably this murder is a weird
situation it was a lawyer suing Imran
Khan for sedition yeah over the whole
issue of how he left power and so on and
he was gunned down yesterday by four
gunmen in the street I mean it is it's a
it's a weird development right yeah
unfortunately assassinations are not
unknown in in Pakistan somewhere
somewhere by islamists uh others or by
you know political opponents and I think
no he is he is brave but he is and he is
at risk and and I do think other
government should speak out in uh in his
favor I agree he shouldn't be harmed I
agree uh let's turn to sports washing or
this whole issue of Morality In Sport
right so Emily I mean we had all this
with the golf yesterday basically after
two years of dumping all over the live
tour for the Saudi money the PGA Tour
takes the Saudi money in poor old Rory
McIlroy that I had to try and pick up
the pieces and said this
whether you like it or not
the pif we're going to keep spending
money in golf at least the PGA turn like
controls how that money is spent
you know so I'd you know if you're
thinking about some you know one of the
biggest Sovereign wealth funds in the
world would you rather have them as a
partner or an enemy
um at the end of the day money talks and
you'd rather have them as a partner I
mean it's what I always thought about
that which is it was never about
morality it was always about oh gash and
control and power but should it I mean
should we care really that Cristiano
Ronaldo Karen Benzema now has gone to
Saudi uh ingolicante is about to go
there as well they offer Messier
billions he's gone to America we'll
probably end up making a billion anyway
from all his deals you know the Middle
East might look at America and say what
about your human rights what about your
invasion of Iraq what's the difference
in other words should we keep the moral
Halos out of all this
no I think if you keep moral Halos out
of everything I mean where's where do we
draw the line where do you draw the line
the sport and morality I I think if I
saw Wimbledon sort of being bought up by
the Saudis I'd feel pretty horrified
what would you why why would you do that
well I guess part of it would also be
that it it would be owned by an an
entity I don't feel 100 about its morals
and it's such a big Wimbledon such a big
thing here right but that's the point so
that's the point once we get into
morality who is without sin enough yeah
oh yeah so then take the place of these
sinful countries yeah I know it's a
question of degree yeah and no one is
defending saudi's record on human rights
but they're investing gigantic amounts
of money into sport ask Newcastle fans
they don't I know you hate them anyway
it's a southern fact they don't they
don't care right they just love the way
their team has got all this money
suddenly should we care where the money
comes from given most countries have
issues yeah I do think we should care
and we should discuss it and you're
quite right I mean look what's in 30
states in the US have the death penalty
in the execute uh you know hundreds of
people every year of course the Saudis
do chopping off hands and uh and the
heads with a really brutal regime but we
know what they're playing at and we know
it is sports watching and they're using
the real to to buy respectability around
the world so I think we've got a we've
got to question that we've got to
challenge that we've got to point that
out now those who say Sport and politics
don't mix well would you have allowed
cricket and rugby and football tours to
a part out South Africa because those
two help bring about change in South
Africa democracy and saw Nelson Mandela
it's a valid point but I do think Saudi
also they I'm sure there is a element of
sports watching too I think they also
genuinely want to invest in sport so the
question for sport then becomes as
golfers decided do you take them out the
billions and improve your game
irrevocable I think it's very hard to
ask Sports people to constantly have to
stand up they are they are at heart they
are sports players they are absolutely
fanatically driven down that line I
think it is up to governments and all of
us to talk about it most of the Chelsea
fans would like Abramovich to come back
which is kind of staggerating and cheer
him in the stands even though we now I
agree
um I want to show you this is a scene
out of Manhattan today look at the smog
it's not like you're saying that obeys
you this is this is this afternoon this
is daylight in Manhattan and this is
from massive fires in Canada yeah and
they're directly apportioning this to
climate change Okay Kevin this is where
I was talking earlier to to Dale yeah
about this this is where I have with
just up oil with all their campaigning
whatever when you see scenes like this
and with them in principle I'm just not
with methodology look we're changing the
world with our activity and we're
changing it for the worse with global
warming and things like this we saw it
in Australia uh a year or two ago we've
seen it in Brazil and look the Canadian
border is 300 North if you've got the
masters from covid you've got to wear
them again in New York off you go yeah
uh great to see you both thank you very
much that's it for me whatever up to
Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]